all right tuesday edition of pft pm as
we do every tuesday during the season we
hand out awards mds joins shireen
williams and me to do that now and let's
get right to it like we always do
offensive player of the week for week 16
mds who do you have
i have ryan fitzpatrick who really put
on one of the performances of the year
in relief of tuataga viloa as that throw
while he was being facemasked thank you
for putting that up at the moment i say
it was just such a phenomenal
play by ryan fitzpatrick he's got such
toughness and grit and all these things
he like about a guy the only thing i
don't like is that he's not starting
week 17. i think he's the better
quarterback on the roster in my humble
opinion he ought to be the starter when
they're fighting for a playoff berth we
shall see how it plays out but he's
definitely my player of the week of week
16 we'll see if we see him on the field
week 17.
mds i took the other obvious choice
which is alvin kamara we all know what
he did and he had six touchdowns and
frankly it should have been seven
touchdowns because taysom hills
shouldn't have gotten the one before
uh alvin kumar got his last one so he
should have set the nfl record alone
with seven touchdowns but he didn't get
that opportunity 22 carries 155 yards
just outstanding and i think maybe mike
that he should make those red and green
christmas shoes
hit his the shoes he wears every single
week even if he has to pay a fine
whatever the fine is just pay it just
build it into your budget for the year
because there was something about those
shoes the shoes that they didn't make
him take off even though they made odo
beckham jr and jarvis landry take off
non-conforming cleats during the 2019
season i still can't get a straight
answer from anyone on
why that was the case for them and not
the case for alvin kamara the grinch
eventually will force him to make a
contribution to the nfl's equivalent of
the human fund but they didn't make him
take off the shoes and that was
something to see six touchdowns fourth
time ever in nfl history the player has
scored six times in a game i thought we
were going to see history of a different
kind on saturday at halftime when tom
brady had 348 passing yards i assumed
that between brady the fact that he was
back in michigan for the last time most
likely in his career and that he was
playing for coach no risk it no biscuit
i thought for sure he would stay in the
game and he would try to get 207 passing
yards in the second half against a
grossly overmatched lions defense in
order to break
a record that goes back to
1951 the single game passing yardage
record more than 20 years before the nfl
decided to embrace passing the football
norm van broglin had 5 54. i thought
that that was the day the record was
going to fall but even without playing
in the second half 3 48 and 4 touchdowns
brady's my offensive player of the week
for week 16. he won't be the nfc
offensive player of the week because of
camara but uh yeah that would have been
an interesting choice
if he had set the single game record and
camara has six touchdowns in the same
weekend which guy is the nfc offensive
player of the week but the league office
doesn't have to figure that one out all
right defensive player of the week mds
who do you have
well i work with steelers linebacker
avery williamson who contributed 14
tackles that was tied for the most that
any player had across the nfl this week
and i just thought that he really
epitomized exactly what the steelers
were hoping for when they made that
mid-season trade to acquire him after
they lost devon bush to a season-ending
knee injury they needed a linebacker who
was going to be
very active showing up a lot and i think
avery williamson at the right time is
becoming that player for them he was
very excited it was the first time he
ever won a division in his career and he
talked about how different that was than
what it was like playing on the jets for
the first half of the season when they
didn't win a game so avery williamson
he's excited he's peaking at the right
time and i think he's one of the players
the steelers are really going to need to
play well in the playoffs
mds the cowboys are going to need randy
gregory to play like he did on sunday if
they're going to have a chance to win
this
this weekend against the giants and have
a chance to win the nfc east and you
know randy gregory has been very open
about his social anxiety disorder he's
been suspended four times for using
marijuana he's one of my favorite
players in the nfl love the kid huge
heart works hard
this time last year he was about to get
a suspension and what he did he went and
worked at the amazon warehouse making
15.50 an hour just to have something to
do and bring home some money to his
family and here he is now back playing
in the nfl had three force fumbles a
sack and a half and this is a guy who
had only had seven sacks in his career
before this weekend and i think he's
really starting to play like the cowboys
thought he was going to play when they
made him a second round pick
yeah i agree with you there and it's
great to see that story and i remember
earlier this year when alden smith was
having great performances he couldn't
get the attention of the folks at park
avenue who hand out the weekly awards or
the monthly word i still think alton
smith should have been the defensive
player of the month for the nfc in
september we'll see if randy gregory
gets some love i think he should be
considered for defensive player of the
week for the nfc although he'll have
some competition in the form of roquan
smith the bears linebacker who was
snubbed for the pro bowl had two
interceptions and a fumble recovery in
that win over the jaguars and the bears
defense is so critical to this this
turnaround you know that we take their
defense for granted but if they can play
at a high level while the offense just
does enough this is a team that is going
to be very difficult to beat if they
make it into the postseason field and
this is one of those teams where if
you're the saints i don't know that
you're all that thrilled the bears
coming to town if you're the seahawks
with no fans there i don't think you
want the bears as your opening opponent
in the postseason run so the bears could
make things very interesting so we give
some credit to roquan smith and the
bears for what they're doing defensively
and getting that 41-17 win over
jacksonville time for the rookie of the
week mds who do you have
i have t higgins the in the first player
chosen in the second round and i don't
know if we've talked enough about what a
good year he's having for the bengals he
had 99 yards and a touchdown in the win
over the texans he only needs to catch
one more pass to break chris
collinsworth's bengals franchise rookie
record for catches in a season he's over
900 yards could hit a thousand yards on
sunday and he's doing it on a team that
of course has had to play three
different quarterbacks i i don't think
we've had much to be excited about with
the bengals in recent years but if joe
burrow is healthy
he and t higgins i think could be a
really exciting combination for many
years to come he looked really good
against the texans helping out a team
that doesn't have a very good
quarterback situation right now i like
the promise that he has to do big things
in cincinnati
mds packers fans moaned and groaned when
the team used a second round draft pick
on aj dillon and frankly he had done
next to nothing 115 yards and no
touchdowns
before this past weekend but he really
went off
first time this season 21 carries 124
yards and two touchdowns and maybe the
packers are seeing something where they
don't resign aaron jones maybe he leaves
him free agency and aj dillon is a
running back but they're going to find
out over the next few games whether he
can do the job and he'll get a chance to
prove that but mike he needs to work on
the lambo leap a little bit
well it's it's hard to leap anywhere
with those legs you got to carry those
legs up over the wall uh and and uh
at least aaron rodgers set a low bar for
the lambo leap this year on aj dillon
though you know the the idea that you
just say to aaron jones thanks for
everything we're going to let you become
a free agent look
for for every for every alvin kamara and
dalvin cook who deliver and also derek
henry on that big second contract
there's one or two other guys that you
scratch your head like ezekiel elliott
like christian mccaffrey who probably
got injured and and i know that it's not
his fault that he hasn't been able to
perform this year but as a running back
if you get injured that's one of the you
know one of the key things that keeps
you from being on the field one of the
things that your team needs so
interesting point that you make do the
packers let aaron jones go uh that'll be
an interesting off-season dilemma for
them for me rookie of the week i am
going with chase young although he's
going to be the defensive rookie of the
year and he's a bright spot on that team
and i suggested at one point joking
around that if you have quarterback
issues just run the single wing and snap
the ball to him i wouldn't want to try
to tackle this guy we've seen what he
can do with the ball in his hands
holding it like walter payton but he is
a force he keeps the washington football
team in every game and if they're going
to win on sunday night on nbc against
the eagles to get into the postseason
they're going to need another big game
from chase young all right let's do
coach of the week mds who do you have
i have a coach we have not yet given our
coach of the week honor here heading
into the 17th and final week of the
season and that is jets coach adam gase
who's now won two games in a row and
both of them against teams fighting for
playoff berths so you have to say that's
pretty legit his players are still
playing hard for him adam giggs has
taken a ton of criticism this year a lot
of it has been justifiable criticism but
you cannot say that he doesn't still
have his players playing hard we've seen
other teams that look like they're
phoning it in at this point in the year
when they're out of playoff contention
the jets are not one of those teams and
i think you do have to give adam jason
credit for that
mds i also picked a coach we haven't
honored this year and that's mike
mccarthy and you know early in the year
he got questioned a lot for some of his
fourth down decisions and fake punts and
fake field goals and everything else he
did well this time he settled for two
red zone field goals and i'm like what
are you doing settling for the two red
zone field goals when you went for it
all year and said you couldn't be scared
but you know what when it works nobody
questioned you afterwards and nobody's
questioning mike mccarthy it's worked
they
since they went three and nine they're
undefeated and they have a chance to win
the nfc smite as unbelievable as that is
yeah it really is unbelievable and it's
unbelievable when you consider how bad
the dolphins were when brian flores
became the head coach and and all of the
the speculation that they were
deliberately tanking in september of
2019 they have really turned it around
since then they're on the brink of the
postseason it's not going to be easy to
get in but flores is my coach of the
week for the way that he just handles
with a steady hand the the quarterback
situation knowing when to yank to a ton
of iowa knowing when to put ryan
fitzpatrick on the field knowing how to
keep fitzpatrick from griping about not
being the starter
going into for example week 17 against
the bills back in buffalo one of the
various places where fitzpatrick once
played not having tongobailoa get his
nose out of joint when he gets yanked
from a game for fitzpatrick knowing
exactly how long to use fitzpatrick so
if it's magic doesn't flip the fitz
tragic it's just amazing how he's gotten
this all to work and we haven't heard a
peep from anyone in the locker room
arguing that what you know what is brian
flores doing what's going on here
they're all on board they've all bought
in it's amazing to see how it has worked
out for miami and it will be sad to see
them not make the playoffs if that's
what happens but between the texans not
the texans already out the titans the
colts the ravens the browns and the
dolphins one of those teams with 10 wins
or possibly 11 is not going to be in the
postseason field all right we say
goodbye to mds we say goodbye to you
just for a second we'll be back with an
unveiling of the new pft power rankings
and a new team at number one we'll be
right back
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports